welcome to another ideas that matter
conversation I have here somebody who
I've interacted with a number of times
and been following in social media who
just crossed a really important
Milestone and this is George George
grumbacher who is a Financial Consultant
uh he's the president of financial
consulting professionals LLC and also
the chief Community officer of money
alignment Academy which maybe you can
tell us about in a little bit he's also
the author of three books the purpose
book your guide to an examined and
aligned life be your own CFO a
business-like approach to your personal
finances and how to get good at money
the keys to financial peace of mind and
prosperity so I think people can see a
common theme running throughout these
but he's also the host of the lifeblood
podcast which recently passed the 2000th
episode Mark which is uh quite an
achievement for any podcast let alone
one that is putting out content I think
five days a week right so uh with Evan
oh Seth you're doing every single day I
thought it was just every business day
but that is an incredible level of
productivity
um so
George do you want to say anything about
this uh Milestone to kick us off
simply that it's uh it's sort of a weird
thing if you were to tell me you're
going to do 2 000 podcasts be like wow I
don't even know how I do that so looking
back on it it's pretty obvious you just
do it every day for about four or five
years so but it's certainly something
I'm proud to have done and it's been an
awesome experience
yeah so I mean I I have a podcast but my
podcast is just taking old video
episodes and editing out ums and Oz and
long pauses and things like that you're
doing original content every single day
now granted with uh guests but that
raises its own
sort of wrinkles right because you've
got to do all this coordination and
figuring out who you want to talk to and
the podcast is we're going to talk about
has an incredible range of of topics in
it so maybe let's start here how do you
go about
figuring out who you want to interview
do you do do research like daily or
weekly is there like a roster of people
that you're looking at
so the show started out just being about
personal financial matters because
that's what my work is so it was
I I started a podcast in 16 with a buddy
just as a hobby I didn't know what
podcasts were prior to 2015 which kind
of sounds weird today because they're so
ubiquitous but back then I'm like I
didn't even know what they were I found
them I'm like these are awesome how cool
they're free there's a podcast on
anything you can listen to them anywhere
they kind of go along with you and it
was before I had kids so I had all this
free time so I thought I'll start a show
and that was you know that was also no
small feat um today it's really easy to
start one back then it was a little
harder
um so I figured out how to do it and
then I thought well maybe I'll start one
for my work you mentioned I do Financial
stuff and so I started out just talking
to other financial advisors I thought
I'll interview really Smart Financial
people and bring their ideas forth try
and serve people that way because you
know with so many things in life we
struggle and we're ready to learn things
when we're ready to learn them right
right so I thought okay I'll try to
bring good ideas out and and that was
sort of what my thought process was so
to answer your question yeah back then
again not everybody was accustomed to
being a guest on a podcast so it was
kind of a weird thing so I would
research and I'd go on social media and
Twitter and try to find Financial
experts or financial advisors and I try
to find their email or connect with them
on LinkedIn or something like that and
I'd reach out and just invite them to be
on the show and early on that was very
time consuming
oh okay and but now is it um I mean
you've got repeat guests uh I I've
noticed that but have you sort of like
built up a whole network of people that
you want to get in on things you know
you're like I I've got that person
pegged for this topic over here that
I've wanted to talk about for a while or
so
things shifted when I made the decision
to broaden the show from personal
finance to just general human
flourishing that's how I refer to this
show today as we're a show about human
flourishing so how do I help people get
better so they can live the lives that
they want that's the idea behind behind
the show and so that gives me the
opportunity to talk to people just just
about any kind of person about whatever
they're most excited about
and so it went from as a show grew
people started to reach out to me and
say hey I'd like to be a guest on your
show oh and that got to the point well
yes yes and no because it kind of made
me lazy okay where now I was just busy
doing versus figuring out who are people
that I really want to have conversations
with now don't take that the wrong way
because I really enjoy 98 of the people
that I have on the show but I'm getting
now back to the point of let's be a lot
more intentional about okay reaching out
to people to talk about
Islam or to talk about artificial
intelligence whatever it might be
yeah I I was scrolling through
um like the most recent hundred episodes
or so and it's a it's a vast variety of
stuff but there is still this theme of
finances and as you know as you put it
um people
ideally living a good life and finances
are a key part of that so I was going to
ask you about this later but it's a good
opportunity to jump into this
um what is the connection I mean there's
there's a lot of people who are like oh
money you know you shouldn't be
prioritizing that you should be thinking
about all these higher values but it
really you know it is hard to live a
good life if you're constantly in debt
or
um you know having to go for lower
options for yourself because you have to
scrimp and save so what what led to that
transition from
you know I'm we're going to focus on
money talk with uh people who are really
interested in and talented and managing
money
um to that realization that this is this
is a an important component of a good
life
foreign
so several things
from a very very very practical
standpoint I wanted to start doing the
show more okay and I was getting tired
of only talking to financial people so I
need to I need to broaden this I I'd
like to be able to talk to people like
like like you uh so I just needed to to
expand the show and and
um the different things that we were
talking about
and doing the show got me back into
writing again just because it got me
back into thinking again as I Was
preparing for guests and not that my
brain was dormant but a lot of the
thinking part of my brain were kind of
dormant I was just in this career which
has been an incredible career yeah but
of just doing and you know doing
Financial stuff which is extremely
interesting and important work but can
be mundane so my brain started working
and thinking and I started just
exploring things personally I started to
think about my beliefs about money and
that led me to beliefs about
relationships and all the different
aspects of of life and to your point
isn't is like why Focus too much on
money well maybe you should maybe you
shouldn't but when you start thinking
about one thing you realize oh it
touches everything else and how is this
impacting all the other aspects of my
life
and it just got me going on all this
stuff and so it's been a journey of
self-improvement and self-discovery and
lots of self-actualization and all this
stuff uh that I've gotten to go on and
you know when you do the show every day
not that I do it seven days a week I
release them seven days a week I'm sort
of getting 20 minutes with with my
guests and I'm getting kind of their
greatest hits you know I'm getting there
some of their best ideas and then I go
out through the rest of my day and I
think about it and it sticks to my head
and I you know it gives me an
opportunity to ruminate and Ponder on
everything so I don't know if I answered
your question there no it's it's
actually a a good segue into something
connected to that I mean one of the
things that you have in your podcast
which is quite nice it you know they are
short
um which I think is helpful for people
but they're not like five minutes so
they're you know you're getting
something substantive but you do ask
um your guests to come up with like one
thing that you can do to improve your
life and I'm curious is that something
that was there from the very beginning
with these financial advisors that you
were talking to or is that something
that kind of crept in as you started
thinking about you know not just money
but life more broadly I think it's a
great feature especially closing with it
you know it it ties everything together
after these uh you know pretty deep
conversations so is that is that
something that just emerged in your
thinking about the podcast
as I was trying to figure out what I
what I wanted the podcast to be and the
kind of show that I wanted to do I try
and start with the end in mind and think
okay I'm gonna do the show and I want to
do it frequently how is that going to
work and how much time do I want to
spend doing this I love listening to
long-form podcasts your Joe Rogan's of
the world your Lex Friedman's of the
world there's so many great podcasts and
hours and hours yeah yeah which is super
cool and part of me would like to be
able to do that but from a practical
standpoint I I can't do that and
certainly if I'm going to do as many as
I do then I can't do that either so it's
more pragmatic thing
and I also wanted to be somewhat
formulaic
and make it pretty repeatable so so
people know what they're they're gonna
get people know what they're gonna get I
the guest knows what they're gonna get
when they sit down and talk to me I know
the conversation we're going to have
sort of at least the framework of it
um so I open the show essentially the
same way I end the show essentially the
same way and
um you know 20 minutes is
to your point it's not five minutes but
it's also not an hour so there's a
little bit of a sense of urgency but
enough time to to to to let ideas
breathe a little bit have you had some
guests who didn't respond well to that
sort of time pressure you know let's
wrap it up folks I mean you could have
like the wrap it up music that you put
as a sound effect right uh where you
know they're they're used to talking for
hours and hours and they they come on
and they're like well I I want more time
has that ever happened or yeah for sure
for sure there's some uh there's some 45
minute episodes uh that are floating
around out there so and I'll let people
go so long as I don't have anything call
time or something like you need to stop
talking sir or ma'am that is enough
yeah with with these uh conversations
usually they're you know 45 minutes to
an hour and a half but I did have one
guest who is a good good friend of mine
I'm not complaining about him in any way
whatsoever but he's very very difficult
to cut off a conversation with and it
went on for about two and a half hours
of recording and we talked for at least
15 minutes before that as well and I've
learned sometimes I need to make sure I
schedule something ahead of time so that
there's a good hard break
yeah you know I'm I'm a big fan of of
upfront
um just setting expectations limitations
yeah limitations expectations and that's
true and and I try and set them up in as
many different kinds of relationships as
I can with my kids with when I'm having
a business meeting whatever it might be
do you need to do that with the podcast
sometimes in terms of content like we're
not going to go here
so you know don't bring that up
um but you know everything else is fair
game you ever have to do that or
thank you
I I um or is it more you just you simply
say listen we're going to focus in on
this you make it more uh I'm not
positive what's going to instead of
saying we're not going to do this you
say we're going to do lots and lots of
this
I don't I don't normally set that kind
of parameter I will ask I'll ask people
if they have any questions okay you know
and then they will say well you know
that'll sort of get them talking or if
they do have if they have a practical
question they'll certainly ask that then
they'll say you know what I really want
to talk about this or I don't want to
talk about that and I always let people
know I say
um the show is very straightforward
we'll introduce you we'll have a great
conversation about you and your work at
the end I'll give you an opportunity to
direct people wherever you want to send
them okay and we'll go for 20 minutes so
I don't want people to feel like they
need to plug something that they want to
plug like I'm going to give you time to
talk about your business book website
whatever yeah yeah
but I never want people to feel like
there's anything that's off limits
um and I want to be respectful people so
if there's something that is off limits
I don't I'm not interested in asking
them about it okay
so um
you you've got all these umbrellas you
know if the the site too is actually
quite nice because you've got all these
categories for the podcast episodes and
you know as you said you started out
with wealth with finances and then uh
there's a tab for health uh lifestyle
relationships I forget all the different
things business
um there's a lot of things on on
productivity and and how to you know
sort of think out your your life but I
noticed there's there's a lot of
episodes on what we could call broadly
philosophical ideas so just
um recently you've got one on Modern
wisdom you know what what actually is
wisdom which is a tough thing to pin
down you ask philosophers and you get
different answers about that but one
that I thought was particularly
interesting is this alternate realities
of you and it starts out thinking about
the Multiverse stuff you know could
there be it's like possible worlds are
there other use in different places but
then it brings a suggests that we could
be in conversation with our ourselves
now this is deeply philosophical and
um you know this seems to be I won't say
it's like the the main topic because
you've got a whole bunch of different
topics but there's a depth of analysis
going on in here so I would imagine some
of my academic philosophy friends you
know who can be a little bit uh elitist
snooty dismissive of other occupations
particularly business right you know
they're the ones that when they have
business majors in their classes they're
like oh these people they don't care
about anything so let's take a minute to
sort of like dispel that
stereotype that people who are people
who are interested in business per se
right and then people particularly who
are doing money management so financial
advisors accountants they're just you
know they're boring their their work is
you know kind of uh as you said mundane
it's it's flattened out they're not
interested in the big questions that
that's totally false right
I mean there are some people who just
they're only interested in the bottom
line but
what have you I mean you've been working
in the business world for I'm guessing
now more than half of your life at this
point so what does your experience been
to people you know in the every once in
a while in the you know the board rooms
or uh wherever else you're you're
meeting bring up philosophical topics
and start exploring them is this is this
an Underside to the business community
that that philosophers Humanities people
just don't know about unless they get
involved with it
probably yes and no right and of course
the answer is it certainly depends there
are
there are
probably the majority of people are not
interested in having these kinds of
conversations but there certainly are
plenty of people who do
uh one of the things that the show did
when I was only talking to financial
professionals was it really restored or
gave me a new hope or faith in the field
because I did talk to so many people who
are very very very thoughtful
now Financial Services is a model it's
this massive thing right it's it's just
just Giant and a lot of it is Cutthroat
and does not care unfeeling
disinterested in that more more more
more
returns profit that
right uh and then there's human beings
that are interacting you know I I always
I have a hard time with Statistics Greg
okay I was like oh look 55 of Americans
are doing this
well if I thought about
people like that then I would have no
hope for Humanity okay when I there is
an example of a company that I'm that I
work with they have like 3 000 employees
and when I go and talk to the HR folks
they're like oh this is an unwieldly
thing I can't steer Battleship how are
we going to make changes the only way
that I can approach my work and my work
is helping people get better at money so
they can live how they want is to assume
and go into every interaction that this
individual that I'm talking to has the
capacity and the ability to change their
life for the better should that be
something that they decide they can
change their story they can they can
rewrite their future so they are not
destined to be in this 55 or 70 percent
of people that will never be financially
successful
So within the financial services
industry this this Behemoth yeah yeah
there are certainly some that are more
philosophical more thoughtful that are
more interested or interested at least
will entertain some of that squishier
kind of touchy-feely stuff that I enjoy
talking about
yeah and and it's um I mean we don't
have to have this massive like wall or
opposition I think that a lot of from my
side a lot of academics do tend to
impose on on that
um you know we sometimes lose sight of
the fact that the people who we
all say idolize as important
philosophers often were entrepreneurs
you know
um you think about Aristotle for example
now you know his dad was a doctor it
doesn't hurt to come from uh some money
especially if you've got powerful
connections to the to the court of the
people who are going to conquer
everything shortly but um you know he
started his own School couldn't actually
own it in his own name so he had his
buddy basically uh be the person to be
the what would you call the owner of
record you know and he studied uh
everything he wanted to and of course he
looked down on working people
um but he you know he was interested
enough in how human Affairs work that he
wrote about just about every aspect of
them that he could including economics
if if the book that's attributed to him
is actually by him which means household
management at that time but you know it
has to do with larger Affairs and I
think that that gets law lost side of us
and so sometimes you know
unfortunately hey there's the The
Stereotype of all these people are only
interested in these things that do
matter but don't really matter that much
um they they lose sight of this and you
know going back to Aristotle so when I
when I teach Aristotle as I'm going to
do again this semester we'll talk about
human happiness and one of the things I
do like about his view on that is you
know being virtuous very important you
got to be fulfilled in life you know uh
you got to be doing good things but he
also says you don't have to be super
rich but you do need to have some money
or else you're going to be unhappy you
know if you're stuck living on the
street the stoics would say oh you can
be perfectly happy even being tortured
on the rack but I think most people look
at that and they're like no that's
that's crazy talk you know uh
Aristotle's a little bit more realistic
about it and so actually let me lead
this into a different uh thing and you
might not have a an answer you're happy
with uh for this but so thinking about
just today let's say we froze which is a
total counterfactual we froze the
economy today so that everything is just
kind of stuck in place and prices don't
go up uh wages don't go up everything
stays more or less the same
um and so you're also not getting a rate
of return on investments either or if
you are exactly the same as it was you
know yesterday
somebody wanted to set themselves up for
a good life in retirement at this point
in time let's assume they're going to
retire at the age of 65. how much would
they actually need in order to be
have all the things that money can
provide them with they can buy what they
want to buy within reason they're not
buying a yacht you know uh or vacations
to the uh Mount Everest or something
like that they need to have enough set
aside for
problems that are going to arise maybe
they need to have money to take care of
kids and grandkids how much do you think
a person if you had to pick like just a
number out of the air you know what a
million dollars that would be enough
for I think so interesting okay I was
imagining a much higher number
um so why would why would you say that
so there's a lot of
it's one thing to save money and then
another to turn money into actual income
I don't think that I want a million
dollars in my 401k because I want that I
want to have a million dollars my 401k
because I can turn that million dollars
into an income that will last for as
long as I need it to that will sustain
the lifestyle that I'm interested in
having okay so you think about if we
were working at GM back in the day or
Ford back in the day would work there
for 30 years we would retire at 65 get a
a crappy gold watch and then we'd have
our pension right and so that was
valuable because we didn't have to worry
about it okay it was money that was just
hit my bank account every month so
essentially you know you you could take
that million dollars
and turn it into
about seventy thousand dollars a year
for the rest of your life whether you
lived 10 years you lived 50 years
so that's a sort of constant rate of
return because we've already assumed
nothing is going to change yeah you got
it you could use a really a very very
very basic Financial product called an
annuity
and people have feelings about that one
way or another I'm just telling you what
it will do probably give you seven
percent so if you put a million dollars
in it'll spit out 70 grand forever
so yeah there you go
now once we reintroduce like Risk into
the equation
um you know a lot of a lot of people
throughout history they want money
because they feel that is going to
insulate them against the various risks
of life
um
when you're dealing with people I mean
obviously we think about financial
transactions in a schizophrenic way
because we're like
um oh this is just hard numbers you know
the numbers don't lie we've got all
these sort of models about that but but
a lot of people's financial decisions
are emotionally driven and emotionally
motivated sometimes they're driven in
the spur of the moment oh the Stock's
going down I better sell all of mine
which terrible decision right uh I gotta
get in on the the frenzy before it it
craters but there's also longer term
stuff and so you've been dealing with
people in this respect for a long time
um obviously fear is one of the emotions
that is driving people but what else is
driving them emotionally
it's such an important thing to to
consider and Daniel Kahneman wrote his
seminal book thinking fast and slow and
he won the uh he won the Nobel Prize he
was the first I think if he was a
psychologist he went into economics or
he was an economist and he went in
Psychology whatever kind of Vice Versa
and his big one of the big big takeaways
that 90 of the decisions we make around
money is based on emotions so that's
that's pretty wild and you think there's
no way that I do that and you start to
think about it like oh yeah wait turns
out turns out a lot of my decision is is
based on emotion
so becoming aware of that and then
paying attention being mindful of what
it is that we're thinking and feeling
and then recognizing it and taking a
more logical approach yeah you you got
it it's like why didn't why doesn't
everybody want to talk about Bitcoin
when it's at fifteen thousand dollars a
Bitcoin it's crickets when it's at
seventy thousand everybody wants to talk
about it so it's exactly what you were
just describing
a lot of us and this is myself included
I I kick off every time I get in front
of a room full of people I say I'm
fortunate to have made a lot of great
financial decisions over the course of
my life and I've made a ton of terrible
ones I've made all the financial
mistakes you can make and I have to say
that so that I'm relatable I'm not
someone okay you know I'm not some Guru
right you know stuffed sued up there who
is just talking about you need to be
contributing this much money and save
and invest and blah blah blah blah blah
that's vapid and it falls flat from my
perspective so I need to be relatable
and then I talk about all the stuff that
I talk about I talk about the the the
the the more squishy stuff I talk about
how important it is to have a compelling
vision for your future that is pulling
you towards it versus me trying to push
myself or White Knuckle myself to do
uncomfortable Financial things so let me
get this straight I'm supposed to cut my
spending just for the sake of cutting my
spending well that's not going to work
that's not sustainable yeah but if I'm
going to take a step back and cut
spending so that I can help my kids do A
B C or D that's more that's more
palatable I can do that
so everything is interrelated I need
yeah to be thinking about what I want
ultimately so it's pulling me towards it
versus me trying to push myself to do
stuff I don't really want to do and live
less that's that sucks so if I
understand you're right you could say
that you've got things that you don't
want to do right so taking the bitter
medicine because it's going to be good
for you cutting your expenses right but
it can be transformed into something
that even though you you wouldn't choose
to do it just for its own sake it can be
something that you actually do maybe
desire to do and you know can take pride
in because you're placing it in a larger
more meaningful framework and it could
be your kids or it could be like
Financial Security so that you can you
know move from a job that you don't like
into a job that you you find more
appealing even though it's not as
remunerative so you know we would call
this figuring out out the not just means
and ends but which ends you should be
pursuing do you have to do when you're
recounseling clients or working with
people in you know seminars do you have
to get them to
open up and say what it is that they
they want and then steer them towards
that or once you've said this to them do
you see like a light bulb go off in
their their head how much how much
Hands-On do you have to be in helping
people figure out uh what's really good
for them and what it is that they really
want and then get them to see money as
part of that
yeah and the answer to that question is
of course it also depends but that that
is my that is my premise that I am I'm
gonna I want to change the conversation
and change the way that people think
about money and relationship that they
have with money and if we can do that
away from just that this is an
intimidating thing or uncomfortable
thing or something I'm bad at
um because that's a whole nother thing
is what I believe what my beliefs around
money and success and wealth and all
these things are so if we can help
people to frame it differently and just
to go just just to get off where I'm
currently at with money and move more
towards this different area I think that
that is helpful
I imagine there's probably two
correlative
um mistaken attitudes that people have
when you just mentioned one I'm bad at
money therefore probably we can spin out
a whole bunch of consoles I'm never
going to be successful it doesn't matter
what I do I'm just screwed because I I'm
not good at this but I imagine at the
other end you have people who think that
their financial Wizards and they it just
never turns out their way you know if
the economy had turned this way uh they
would have made a killing but
unfortunately you know they bought you
know I don't know some crazy commodity
they shouldn't be doing Commodities
trading they invested in in crypto in
the wrong time or nfts think about that
you know oh we're going to change change
the entire Academy with with nfts so
um you know I hope that most clients are
somewhere in in between that but you you
must have to deal with people at times
who think that they understand things
better than they do and so in a way
um to bring up another philosophical
person that's sort of like you know what
we call
um Socrates alankas is like showing
people no they don't know as much as
they think so It prepares the way for
saying okay now let's let's do this
um do you end up having to do that with
uh clients and you know if you do so
obviously you're probably not like
deflating them like Socrates did because
you don't want them to feel terrible but
um you do have to like you know say no
no you're you're actually this is this
is wrong your your information is wrong
this is why you're having trouble so do
you have clients like that who you have
to uh
steer away from their own uh presumption
of knowledge when they don't have it
for sure for sure I think that we all we
all interact with money so therefore you
know and you've been interacting with
money for however long you've been
interacting it so have I just like I've
been driving so yeah I think I'm a
better driver than all the other drivers
on the road right we all have these yeah
yeah these overconfidence biases
um and so yeah for sure I try to I try
and approach it I try to disarm people
so I you know I'm not trying to present
myself as an expert I'm trying to
present myself as somebody who has
experienced similar problems to what you
are potentially experiencing and let me
share with you how I've found the
solution or what's worked for me to help
to get there and then I'll certainly
present information that is for lack of
a better term factual and the numbers
base so you sort of present from uh from
an emotional standpoint and then back it
up with with with logical kind of stuff
like the conversation about why a
million dollars is a worthwhile goal for
saving money what that translates into
um
that's compelling enough to move some
people to action
but for a lot of people we need a little
bit more work and a little bit more
thought to go into it than just okay got
it check I'm going to start saving a
thousand dollars a month and I'll do
that for the next 20 years and I'll have
that million dollars and then I'll have
the 70 and I'm good and then they do it
it's amazing but that's less common than
it is common
it's interesting because the the
approaches that you're mentioning it it
like corresponds almost exactly to when
Aristotle in the art of rhetoric is
talking about the three main modes of
persuasion uh there's logos providing
some sort of a counter argument in this
case it'd be you know statistical
reasoning look if you if you do this
this is going to happen here uh here's
what compounding interest looks like you
know and then there's uh pothos which is
the emotional side which needs to be
explored as well but then there's this
dimension of ethos which Aristotle
actually says is the most convincing of
the means to persuasion and we translate
that as character but you know when I
think about what he says throughout the
rest of the work the sort of thing that
you were talking about the approach of
listen I'm not coming down from on high
with as an expert who simply knows
everything that's the logo side
um I've made some of the same mistakes
I'm relatable and I he also says too
that part of what makes a speaker
um persuasive in this respect is that we
not only think they're competent and
decent people but they have good will to
us they you know in Greek that they care
about us is a way we would say it you
know so you know I care that uh you know
um this person is financially successful
even though they're just a client
they're they're not you know my my
friend my buddy my family member but to
have that you know projection of care
um which I you know I think people can
fake it for a while but not not very
long you know if you're going to have an
ongoing relationship that has to be uh
sustained by being genuine
um so it's interesting that you say this
because you put all three of these
together and you get a very
powerful
package you could say for getting people
to do the things that you you want them
to do and in your case it's not just oh
I want to sell you a product it's more
like you said I want people to
understand money so they can live a
better life so you've got a message and
you're projecting it out there using all
of these techniques now was that
deliberate on your part did you did you
at some point say ah you know
um I need to attempt to the emotional
side but I also need to do this and I
need to do this or did you just kind of
happen into it successfully
I can remember being or sitting in a
meeting and the gentleman his name was
Randy Marshall got up and he was talking
about how people seek a purpose-driven
life and you have the ability to help
them get it yeah and this was in the
context of recruiting people into the
financial industry okay so there was six
years where I did that function and that
really taught me because that really
clicked with me you know Moses without
Vision the people perish and
and people want to feel good about their
work and people want to feel good about
it's there's a lot of people that most
people don't want to be Financial
experts they just want to know that I
have peace of mind that what I'm doing
is going to translate into the result
that I want
so
am I smart enough to put all that
together
um maybe
um but I think just over time because
I've been doing this for you know 23 24
years yeah realizing what is going to
actually get somebody's attention yeah
yeah that is the most important thing
because we've so it varies from client
to client right so sometimes you'll be
more on The Logical approach sometimes
more on the emotional
for sure for sure and I don't I don't do
a lot of individual financial planning I
message to large groups of people so I
am I am a I work with Working Class
People that is those are the folks that
that I'm interested in working with and
who I do interact with most commonly
um there are a lot of wonderful
financial advisors out there who are
doing very sophisticated Financial stuff
and that's not me I'm talking about the
blocking and the tackling the behaviors
yeah um and just recognizing
everything that goes into money it's so
charged we're embarrassed we have shame
our parents told us to never talk about
it with anybody else and that's not good
you know that's if I am struggling with
something the opposite of what I should
be doing is just putting my head in the
sand so I recognize that and I felt that
way too I've I have also had these
feelings and still occasionally do
so I I I get it and I think I'm I'm a
very empathetic person whether my wife
would tell you that that's the case or
my friends would tell you that I think
that they would all kidding aside yeah
um
so I try and have conversations with
people the way that that I want to
process information while also being
respectful and trying to figure out how
they want to receive information so
that's yeah that's incredibly important
going back to the aspect of rhetoric you
know I mean Aristotle got that he he
says every kind of teaching involves
persuasion you got to get people
interested in what you're saying and you
know we you've we've all had professors
who didn't know that lesson they assumed
that whatever it is that they're saying
or I mean people do presentations like
that right they put up a PowerPoint and
they're like you're gonna find this
fascinating because I do you know and
then our our eyes are glazing over yeah
um so that's yeah that's quite important
I want to go back to the thing about
working people so
in a way what you're doing
in terms of like human happiness gets a
much greater bang for for the buck
because you are speaking to large
numbers of people and there's way more
working-class people than there are you
know people who have the the financial
resources to engage in these very
sophisticated schemes that you were just
referencing before and and maybe with
Mark when we talk about marginal utility
I mean you buy your second yacht how
much of a boost do you get from that
compared to actually
not being in debt paying off a mortgage
being able to send your kid to college
and uh you know not say oh we can't
afford anything we can actually take you
out for dinner you know these kind of so
they seem kind of trivial but but
they're actually very important for for
people when I talk to my students the
things that they remember are precisely
those that Mom and Dad took them to this
place in Milwaukee and it was it was
great because it was you know out of the
ordinary for them they couldn't afford
it so
um did you choose was this a deliberate
thing where you're like listen I want to
work primarily
with and Reach working-class people to
help them better understand money or was
it just you know something that you
happened into or is there a combination
of both where you're at a certain point
you're like holy crap this is what I'm
doing and let me get good at at doing
this
yeah well I appreciate that question
um there's so many different ways to
have a successful Financial Services
career
um I started out selling life insurance
so I did that for seven years and then I
went into management within that sort of
Arena and did that for six years and
after that 13 years I kind of looked
around said where do I fit in do I fit
into this at all to financial services
and
it was sort of uh you know
whatever the term there is an
existential moment and I settle down
exactly yeah yeah you know
um essentially retirement planning and
that brought me to working with 401K
plans for companies because it gave me
the opportunity to work with large
numbers of people without
without doing it one at a time so I get
the opportunity to go into these
companies and to do the kind of work
that we've been talking about and to
message and the vast majority eighty
percent of Americans or whatever the
number is most will never interact
one-on-one with a financial professional
or financial advisor it's just the way
that it is so I view my work as how do I
bridge that Gap or close that Gap using
technology and everything that's
available to me to have an interaction
without
kind of having that one-on-one
interaction yeah now so coming back to
the podcast in a way the podcast
supports that kind of work
um and I think you know so let's think
about the sort of stereotypes of
ordinary working people
because they're not so
um interested in finances or they think
I'm I'm bad at money they might not
actually listen to a podcast about money
matters because you know they're like
well that's not for me that's for
smarter people than me and we do we know
that like Working Class People Talent
intelligence is pretty well distributed
across every Vector it's not like you
know uh people working in the c-suite
are actually way smarter than everybody
else that's just not the case you know
and you can see this in universities too
that Elite universities professors and
you know people working in Community
College not a huge difference other than
access right so
um
if you if you wanted to make a pitch a
really broad pitch to why the ordinary
working Joe or Josephine should listen
to the podcast now it's not just a
podcast about money as we pointed out
it's all sorts of other things as well
um and you weren't just going to use the
the pitch that you you use over and over
again which is a great pitch by the way
but you have to like pick something
different how would you do it what pitch
would you make to them
to
listen to the podcast yeah new a new
audience
yeah yeah I'd say
that it's not it's not the the AM radio
Financial talk oh that that that people
who are interested in that kind of thing
would enjoy I think that if you are a
financial
if you're an avid personal financial
person or an avid stock market investor
you probably won't enjoy the podcast
you'll probably find it to be too basic
um but if you are somebody who's
interested in listening for a short
little 20-minute amount of time and
learning something that you can take and
put to work in your life immediately
then it's probably a good show for you
it's not going to teach you the ins and
outs of of Taxation on International
entity it's not going to do that but
it'll teach you from a behavioral
standpoint how to create a good new
habit or how to reframe thinking about
something that you're uncomfortable with
yeah how to overcome a problem you've
been struggling with it'll give you
Frameworks step by step
how do I put this actually into action
um hopefully quickly
okay I think that that's a great pitch
so now I got a couple questions for you
about the podcast and I think to some
people some some guests and perhaps to
some listeners or viewers they would
seem like they're softball questions but
I suspect that they're not
because you've got over 2 000 episodes
now
so if I ask you what is your favorite
episode is that a question you can
actually answer or is it like you know
people ask me like who's your favorite
band and I'd be like well if I was 16 I
could say Iron Maiden but I've got so
many that I really really like and you
know deciding is this one better than
this one I I find myself incapable
sometimes so what's what's your response
to
favorite uh episode of your own podcast
I've had a guest on named Jamie Lerner
and she is a I think she's a
psychotherapist
she's been on twice and she gave me the
language of you have choice
and
it's so simple and so profound
that from a stoic standpoint we know
that you know I don't have control over
the circumstances but I get to choose
how I think feel and respond to those
circumstances and her framing of it you
have choice you get to choose how you
feel
about everything
you choose nobody else saying well and
she told me I was wrong a couple of
times too which is great you know I try
to try it out you know I'm like oh I'm
trying to figure it out like how does
that work she's no no uh
so I'd say if I had to pick one or two
probably that episode with Jamie the
first one
um so that would be my answer
well that's great I I thought maybe you
wouldn't people you'd be like ah there's
so many you know something like how do
you how do you balance them out but you
know being able to give a a fundamental
reason for it that's that's quite
important
um I'm not going to ask you like what
was the least favorite uh one but were
there anywhere I'll put it to you this
way where something went off the rails
could be technical could be like sort of
you thought the person was going to be a
great guest and they just like wouldn't
talk it's dead air or something along
those lines and what then what did you
do
for sure well in you know after doing
something for five or six years however
long it's been we've screwed stuff up
big time for sure and had to re-record I
think I've gone through an entire
interview without recording it like oh
no so I had to reach out to the person
be like we had a great conversation but
we need to do it again if you'd be
willing to do that
how did they take to that everybody's
been very understanding of it you know
we know that that stuff happens so
but to a person whenever somebody comes
on and we're having our Chit Chat
beforehand and this has happened
probably five times they say oh I'm
really looking forward to a great back
and forth and having a great
conversation I'm like uh oh and they
just talked the entire time I introduced
them and that was it I could have just I
could have left the room
literally
so is that like a tell tell phrase for
that then well it's it has been and when
people are just like we're gonna have
just this great back and forth
discussion like that's what I was
assuming we're going to do
maybe the fact that they needed to like
emphasize it is exactly yeah that's a
red flag
I can I can zone out of this one
yeah so what's what do you have planned
next for the podcast is it I mean it's
an incredible pace of of work
um you could just like keep doing what
you're doing and that would be awesome
but are there any other
ideas that you're kicking around or you
know format changes or things like that
on the horizon
so discovered a couple years ago that we
had so many guests in kind of this cool
community of folks that are their
Consultants or their writers they have
offerings so we created the website I
appreciate you checking it out I'm proud
of that where people can come and and
listen to the shows obviously they can
read written content from our guests
they can engage directly transcripts are
are awesome and they also a lot of them
will will provide blog content for the
site
um they have the coaching there's
courses that are it's it's all it's all
guest generated I guess that's so it's
kind of a cool ecosystem and we're
looking to just expand offerings and be
a place where people can come and the
whole idea is is to get better so I see
a world where we do consistent monthly
events and there's the six areas of the
show that you mentioned it's wealth
success business
um lifestyle relationships health at in
health thank you where we can do like
one of our guests will will do a live
kind of a session where people can come
in and check it out so stuff like that
we just released a journal with guests
contributions to it so trying to figure
out new ways to to kind of make the make
the show different and better and always
iterating I am yeah that's not sure of
ideas yeah that's that's very cool um to
create an online community is difficult
you know
and then to not just create it and get
people to come in but to sustain it and
to get them
to not this is one thing I haven't
managed to to do myself because I've got
you know this big YouTube following and
all that
um people will talk to me a lot right
and the YouTube stuff has led to all
sorts of opportunities you know for my
own coaching or speed you know giving
speeches or things like that but um
getting the people to directly interact
with each other within a network where I
can like step back and say all right I'm
leaving the room now that that hasn't
happened for me but I mean from what
you're saying here there's a common
umbrella and then people are able to
interact with each other so
it's not quite like a professional
association and it's clearly you know
very diverse
um but that's that's quite admirable I
mean doing that is not something
easy everybody wants to like create a
new online community but you're actually
succeeding in it
well nobody's cracked the code and when
I say nobody I mean me I have not
cracked that code Greg I'm just that's
just that's that in my mind's eye that
is
I try to think about how I want to spend
my time in the work I'm interested in
doing how would I like to be interacting
with people and I would like to be doing
more of that so I'm going to be working
on it and if nothing else I am
persistent and consistent so well that's
that's so important right
and and uh not actually let me ask you
this because we're getting close to the
end of time
so to persevere in things to be
persistent to be consistent which is
um I think underrated a lot of people
think oh I have to have a great plan or
I have to have a lot of you know just
like Stellar Talent or something or I
need to be on all the time but really
that's not sustainable we need to be
working not at 100 all the time but just
constantly seeing things through
um so here's Here's the the the
questions obviously that leads to
generating uh good content that people
can uh consume uh enjoy get some some
benefit from so leads to the podcast
leads to these other extensions and
expansions of the community
um but a lot of people I you know and I
say this with students especially
they'll be like well I just don't have
that I can't stick to things you know
um some people can I see it it's cool
that they can do that but that's that's
just not me
um going back to the choice thing you
don't want to say well it's a matter of
choice and that's why you're a lazy
person right because that's not helpful
at all but how do you coax people into
realizing that they can actually have
that stick-to-itiveness to use a
old-fashioned way of talking about it
um and that you know that's that's a
possibility for them how do you get them
to see that
I think that that all the behavior
changes that I think about in my life
personally it's all very similar whether
I want to lose weight whether I want to
get out of debt whether I want to learn
a little new language or whatever
there's there's a couple of really
interesting things going on there
um one is that we have this superpower
slash weapon of mass destruction which
is my ability to rationalize things and
to rationalize where I am
and rarely do I do that for my benefit
it's more eh you know what that's for
other people it's cool that this George
guy has done 2 000 podcasts but there's
you know that's just not for me you know
I'm I I have too many other obligations
I can explain why I'm not doing that or
why I am where I am I can figure out a
way to make that make sense pretty
quickly and what that does is it just
makes us small it causes us to not go
after the things that we truly want so
that's why it's a weapon of mass
destruction so I always try to catch
myself am I doing this am I screwing
myself am I holding myself back have I
created a a glass my own self-imposed
glass ceiling or glass cage and that is
where the limiting belief stuff comes in
if I think that I'm bad at money I'm
gonna be bad at money
so I need to identify where it is that I
am screwing myself over I'm just bad at
relationships
yuck that's a self-fulfilling prophecy
whatever so identifying where when those
are popping up
and then like Jamie Lerner was talking
about well how do I want to feel about
that
do you want to feel like you're bad at
money
no oh okay well then change the way that
you are talking to yourself and thinking
about it and to degree it's that easy
you're better served by trying to pull
that string and figuring out why it is
you think that for me it was just how I
grew up my family didn't have enough
money my mom would pay bills once a
month and she spread out all of our
bills on our wooden dining room table
and my brother and I knew to stay away
because it was stressful so month after
month after month year after year after
year just taught me stay away from money
stuff and that manifested in me being
bad at money until I realized what my
head was telling me to do once I
recognized it then I could shift that
say here's how I want to feel about it
okay yeah yeah it's not instantaneous
but it's closer than you think all these
changes are closer than you think so I
sort of went off on you there but it's
such an unfortunate that's actually a
great message
the changes are closer than you think
yeah
that could actually be like um a little
slogan that uh
could put heart into people so we're
almost at the top of the hour I want to
be respectful of your time uh where are
the best places to find you other than
just putting uh the the podcast into
Google uh lifeblood podcast it's the
first result that comes up where where
else can people find you
if people are interested in um it's
lifeblood.live is the website for the
show obviously appreciate you talking
about the podcast if people are
interested in my other work it's money
alignmentacademy.com
and you mentioned the purpose book at
the beginning I'm super proud of that
it's uh it's available I haven't
officially launched it whatever that
means but you can find the purpose book
on Amazon as well
okay well thank you so much for uh
giving uh some time in your morning I
know it's very early there uh in in
Arizona it's early here in Milwaukee so
thanks for coming on
yeah and I'm grateful
for the friendship that we've developed
over the past five or six years you've
been on the left blood podcast four
times I think Greg so that's been
awesome and they have certainly been
without question some of my favorites
and if you want to yeah if you want to
check out the uh the
if you want to see my learning uh take
place in real time listen to the first
time we talked and then listen to the
last time we talked and I think that
you'll see that uh that I improved as a
host and hopefully a thinker as well so